I've traveled to Ashkelon the coastal
city just south of Tel Aviv that nudges
up against the Gaza Strip what you were
seeing here right now is the launcher
launcher has 20 missiles on it you can
see the red light flashing which means
it's armed and ready here one of the
dozen or so Iron Dome batteries sits at
the ready to intercept missiles and
provide Israel with the type of shield
from aerial attacks in the orange zone
commander Lieutenant Colonel LaRon Cohen
oversees its operation is this as close
as we get or do we get as close as we
got
it took just three years and about 200
million dollars to develop this defense
system it relies on a radar that
instantly detects when a missile has
been fired
algorithms quickly try to determine what
type of projectile is in the air and
whether it's heading for a populated or
strategic area if so I until launches a
missile of its own it said that Iron
Dome has taken down more than 1,000
missiles since it turned on in 2011
with a 90% success rate
some people question the accuracy of
these figures what's clear though is
that the algorithms capable of directing
projectiles while performing a
cost-benefit analysis on human life are
among the most advanced in the world
this network of launchers is highly
mobile and constantly on the move this
site like many is temporary
everything you see here can be moved out
in a matter of hours and we move around
a lot to make sure nobody knows what we
are all the time unless you live here
it's difficult to imagine just how much
this technology has transformed the
lives of ordinary Israelis I can tell
you from my own personal experience
sitting in my own house and seeing
rockets fired towards my house and
operating this is an incredible system
and succeeding but they are in dome when
you see your house that you're
protecting and your family and your
friends and your soldiers it's a sense
of a great sense of pride
for many Palestinians Iron Dome means
something else it's just the most
visible part of an expansive Israeli
security apparatus that includes drones
checkpoints and espionage technology
those tools have been put to immediate
use in the West Bank Gaza and throughout
Israel terrorist bombings have declined
missiles have met their match but lower
tech forms of protest like stabbings
are now on the rise